foreign
view a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with the chief
leader writer of The Observers on your
soda and the chief executive of the
total politics group Mark Wallace great
to see both of you as ever front pages
the guardian leading on that verdict
that the former U.S president Donald
Trump sexually abused columnist e Gene
Carroll in the 1990s that story also
making the front page of the Daily
Telegraph
and the Daily Mirror the paper writing
that Donald Trump was ordered to pay his
accuser 3.9 million pounds or 5 million
dollars after jurors ruled that he did
sexually assault her
and the verdict is also the lead story
on the front page of the Metro Trump is
a sex abuser
meanwhile the Archbishop of Canterbury
is set to condemn the government's
illegal migration bill and the language
being used by ministers
the express says that analysis shows the
effect of diabetes means that more than
7 000 people die needlessly with the
disease every year
and the financial times reporting that
according to officials the compensation
bill for those affected by the NHS
contaminated blood Scandal could reach
10 billion pounds
well a reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers will you watch our
guests let's head straight to them Sonia
soda and Mark Willis a hasty rewrite for
many a newspaper Sonia the guardian for
example amongst many that pick up on
this fact that Trump has now been found
guilty of sexually abusing a writer back
in the 1990s yet again extraordinary
stuff
absolutely it's a huge story uh from the
US a civil jury in the U.S in New York
state has found that Donald Trump did
sexually abuse a writer Eugene Carroll
in a New York Department Store in either
1995 or 1996 they didn't find that there
was enough evidence to say that he had
raped her but the sexual abuse finding
is extremely serious it's a civil case
so she's been awarded civil damages of
five million dollars as he said that
Donald Trump will have to pay her and
it's a really significant finding
because it is the first time that a
sexual assault claim allegation against
Donald Trump of which there are many and
in fact two women who also say that he
sexually assaulted them decades ago gave
evidence as part of this case but it's a
first time that these allegations have
been
examined by a court in this case it was
a civil case in New York state so really
really significant but the question I
think on everyone's Minds is as well as
you know I think this the fact that this
is an awful thing that Donald Trump has
found uh to have done and you know
thinking about the impact that that will
have had on the woman that he sexually
abused but you know the the question
that lots of people will be thinking
about is the implications of politics
does this impact on Donald Trump's
chances of getting uh selected as the
Republican candidate for U.S president
um in the next set of U.S presidential
elections and so far I think the
consensus seems to be you know these are
very grave um findings that U.S Jury has
made against him but that
um they probably won't affect his
standing with people who already like
him in the US with Republican voters who
are minded to vote for him anyway in the
primaries I mean that is extraordinary
isn't it the Metro Trump is a sex abuser
uh you know a headline no doubt repeated
across the U.S newspaper is and yet
every time you know a case is brought
against him
um it seems his poll rating goes up Mark
what's going on
I think a number of things are going on
firstly it is really important to note
exactly as Sonia just said the the you
know this is a significant and serious
and important funding particularly of
course for the woman who brought these
allegations and bought this case against
him to have her allegations borne out in
this way and also for the two women who
um step forward to give evidence about
um similar allegations during the course
of the case that is not an easy thing
for anybody to end any circumstances but
particularly in a politically charged uh
case in a media Spotlight in an age of
um you know personality Cults and
conspiracy theorists and you know
instituted to the credit that they did
so and I hope that they feel that
they've got some modicum of uh justice
even through a civil course as a result
of this finding but what's troubling of
course is that we we knew quite a lot of
this um to one degree or another about
Donald Trump because he told us so
before his first election we all
read and read the transcripts of him
talking about grabbing women by their
genitalia we heard other allegations
along these lines we saw the way in
which he dismissed and his fans
dismissed things like that tape about
grabbing women as being locker room
banter
um and we saw the way in which sadly had
no effect seemingly on the electorate
and so I think we are at the point now
where things are so polarized in terms
of whether you you know if you happen to
like Donald Trump there's a troubling
tendency to therefore mean that you have
to dismiss anything native about it and
you have to believe everything uh
positive about him
um and admittedly sometimes vice versa I
think a lot of this is already you know
if you're concerned about this fact
about Donald Trump you probably already
dislike him
um people ought to be more concerned
about it and his fans you know so-called
conservatives members of the so-called
Moral Majority people who Count Their
religion as part of their
um you know political decision making
should be horrified to buy this and
should be opposed to him but quite a lot
of those decisions should already have
happened yeah I mean and that's a very
important point isn't it is it all just
priced in with Donald Trump you know
this he's fighting to be once again the
most important man in the world
effectively and yet you know his base uh
called a cult by the Lincoln project who
I spoke to a short time ago Republicans
who are opposed to Donald Trump
um you know it's all it's all just
factored in isn't it Sonia
I think the worrying thing is it may
well be and U.S politics is extremely
polarized around a number of issues
around women's rights abortion rights
being won for example
um you know these sorts of allegations
being another I think and I think that
polarization is very bad for U.S
politics but it probably does provide
Donald Trump with a degree of insulation
against
you know feeling a political Fallout
from and when you take a step back it's
just incredible I mean this is a former
U.S president who we know wants to be
president of the United States again you
know he's going to throw his hat into
the ring for the Republican nomination
uh for president he's been found guilty
by a civil jury of sexually abusing a
woman there are numerous other
allegations that stand against him you
know in normal political times you would
think you know in U.S politics sort of
you know 30 40 years ago that might have
knocked somebody out of the running
um but it just seems incredible that
somebody who has been found guilty of
this by a U.S jury you know he has to
pay a woman five million dollars in
Damages it probably isn't going to do
his political chances um that much harm
in terms of you know his standing in the
Republican party because
um sadly there are enough people who I
think won't be bothered by this
um I think there is you know the
question though of what happens
obviously when it if he does get the
Republican nomination as lots of people
expect him to do so you know what
happens when he comes up against
um Biden in the presidential election
itself that still is very much up in the
air and all the polling is saying that
you know points towards the fact that
Biden is probably would probably win
yes and you talked about The Bravery of
e Gene Carroll uh she's in her late 70s
Mark um she has issued a statement I
filed this lawsuit against Donald Trump
to clear my name and to get my life back
today the world finally knows the truth
this Victory is not just for me but for
every woman who has suffered because she
was not believed and certainly she was
seen leaving the courthouse having not
made a statement so that's the statement
then from E Gene Carroll uh The Daily
Telegraph um picking up on what you said
the trial featuring evidence from two
other women who claim Mr Trump had
sexually assaulted them decades ago as
well Natasha stoned off a former
reporter at People magazine told jurors
that Mr Trump had cornered her it is
Mar-A-Lago club in Florida in 2005 and
forcibly kissed her for a few minutes
until a butler interrupted Jessica Leeds
testified that Mr Trump kissed her
groped her and put his hand up her skirt
on a flight in 1979 and they also heard
excerpts from that 2005 Texas Hollywood
Video in which Mr Trump made remarks
about women which you referenced Mark
and certainly his uh Donald Trump's
lawyer his attorney suggesting that that
should not have been part of this trial
and using that as a reason to bring an
appeal you know saying Mr Trump um is
strong and he's a Survivor which is we
we all know it appears to be the case
uh yes I mean all all sorts of creatures
survive all sorts of circumstances and
analogies that I weren't particularly
such but they you know when
unfortunately what's going to happen you
know one of the reasons this trial this
case um rather this lawsuit arose was
that Mr Trump called his accuser a liar
and she felt quite rightly it turns out
the jury agreed that he was uh defaming
her and damaging her reputation by
falsely claiming that she was lying
about something which the jury has now
reviewed the evidence and believes
happened and his the the fact that you
see firstly his lawyers you say saying
well you know the evidence of his own
words in the past should not have been
brought into this trial I think is quite
extraordinary and more extraordinary and
why this wider Society if not always for
this particular former president and
secondly Mr Trump himself saying this is
a Witch Hunt well the famous thing about
witch hunts is indeed the whole point of
which I'm becoming an analogy and a
reference point in the first place is
the allegations weren't true and this is
the opposite of a Witch Hunt we have a
jury who has reviewed this evidence
we've heard these Witnesses and has
reached a conclusion I've no doubt he'll
throw more money and more lawyers at
appeals and uh and and you know and a PR
campaign to money the water further but
it's muddy in the water they got him
into this position in the first place uh
Daily Mirror Sonia uh Trump the sex
attacker uh due rules he did assault um
a woman and orders him to pay uh four
million pounds in Damages as they put it
daily mail as well is this the end of
Trump's new bid to be president
um but you can fight to become president
campaign from behind bars so uh you know
it's to answer that question in the mail
it's unlikely
hmm
Sonia
oh I did if you can hear me hi Sonia
hi I can hear you now but I lost you for
a while
I was just I was suggesting that the
question posed there in the Daily Mail
is this the end of Trump's new bid to be
president uh the answer could well be no
because you can campaign to be president
from behind bars there
yeah and this wasn't a criminal trial of
course I mean that may yet still be to
come I suppose but um it's a Civil Trial
so that's why it's resulted in payment
of this massive um you know these
massive damages from Donald Trump to
Eugene Carroll but yeah I mean this is
basically where American political
analysts seem to be coming down on which
is that you know it's not really going
to affect us chances of uh becoming U.S
president there's a there's a it's a
mountain he's got to climb that's for
sure because it's obviously not just
about getting the Republican nomination
it's about winning against Biden in a
general election uh and and that looks
far far from certain if you look at the
polling date at the moment in fact it
favors Biden but you know in terms of
does this harm of his chances of getting
the Republican nomination as we've been
discussing
um no one really seems to think that it
does